[موسيقى]
عملت منذ عشرات السنين على جمع هذه
المقتنيات لاشباع رغبتي كهاوي لهذه المهنه
للحرف اليدويه بشكل عام الذي اذا اردتها
كما سبق عن ابائى لغرض التعريف بها كثورات
ثقافي انسانيه وتبادل ثقافي بين الشعوب
لان هذه مشغوله تمثل هذه
هذا العنوان حصلت على هذه المقتنيات
المعروضات عابر جمعها وشرائها من الاسواق
ومن اصحابها عبر عشرات السنين وضمها
لتكوين متحف للموروث الثقافي
ليثري ثقافته حضاره الثلاثي اليمني بشكل
عام
[موسيقى]
اي
حاجه تمثل الموجودات والمقتنيات التي تم
جمعها من مجموعه نادره تمثل لانها انقرضت
من الايدي ومن الاسواق ومن المنازل
فجميعات مثل
قطعها هامه
لانعدامها كما سبق وقيمتها التاريخيه
فلدينا هنا قطع تعود الى مئات السنين مئات
سنه من عدم العصر العثماني ومن عهد العسل
الامامي الاول ومن عهد عصر الامام احمد
ومن وما بعدها حتى تاريخ هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
نحن في اطار هذا الصدد نسعى تنفيذ اتفاقيه
الصوم الثلاثي الثقافي الذي اعتمدت
اليونسكو للحفاظ على هذه الممارسات
والمعارف التي تتناقلها الشعوب من
شعب الى الشعوب الاخرى
لغرض التبادل الثقافي وفي هذا الصدد عملنا
على اعداد ملف اليمن للنقش على المعادن
وتم ارساله الى اليونسكو ان شاء الله في
عام 2023 لكي تدرك بعض الحرف اليدويه
ومنها حفظ صياغه الفضه كعرفه يدويه على
قائمه التراث العالمي تحت الحمايه الدوليه
لانها حرف اصبحت هائله لانقراض وهناك عده
مشاريع طموحان نسعى للتنفيذها وقد شرعنا
في تنفيذ الاجزاء كثيره منها منها عدد
مركز الحرف اليدويه في مع الهيئه العامه
بالاشتراك مع الهيئه العامه للاثار يسعى
هذا المركز الى الحفاظ على خمس حرف يدويه
الى الانقراض وهي حرفه الفضه وحرفه النعاس
والنقش على القصيه الجبسيات وصناعه الجلود
والنحت على الاخشاب وجميع هذه الحرف كانت
موجوده في اليمن لانها اصبحت الان منقرضه
تماما
[موسيقى]
المحل يحتوي على مجموعه من السيوف النادره
تعتبر السيوف نادره كونها مغلفه بالفضه
وتعود لحقها بزمنيه تتراوح اعمارها ما بين
4500 العام
الحديد حقها من الفولاذ الممتاز الذي كانت
تشتهر به اليمن
تعود الى حقك زمنيه مختلفه تبدا من 500
العامل 400 الى 300 عام حتى بدايه وجود
الاسلحه الناريه المحل كذلك يحتوي على
مجموعه من العقود النسائيه التي تمثل التي
تلبس النشام الكهرمان ومن الملبوسات
الفضيه التي تستخدم في العادات والمناسبات
في الاربعينات والاعراس والافراح وغيرها
كذلك المحل يحتوي على مجموعه من الجنابير
رجاليه المتنوعه التي تعكس الجغرافيه
اليمنيه سواء في الساحل ام في الجبل ام في
محافظه صنعاء ام في محافظه اخرى
كذلك المحل يحتوي على مجموعه نادره من
العمل
الورقيه التي تعود الى بدايه العملاء
الورقيه من بدايه
1962 وحتى هذا اليوم والمحل يحتوي على
كذلك على مجموعات من القطاع الفضيه التي
تعتبر نادره وهي مشغولات لعده مدارس
صناعيه يمنيه مدرسه ظهرت من بدايات العامه
19 وحتى اليوم نحن نواكب انتاجات
الصناع الصناع لهذه الاشياء ونجمعها تكون
نموذجات تحفظ كنموذجات وارشيف حرفي يستفيد
منه الاجيال كذلك المحل يحتوي على مجموعه
من الاعمال الخشبيه
المتنوعه
محليه ومن ثقافه اخرى تم جمعها لانها
تبادل الثقافي والانسان وكذلك مجموعات من
القطاع النحاسيه
وخليط من العقيق والخواتم وغيرها من اشكال
التي تمثل العمل اليمني
[موسيقى]